Speaker 1: All right.
Let's check out a sort of good old fashioned
conspiracy theory.
This one combines the globalist.
You know how Alex Jones always uses that term?
Globalist, internationalist, Trotskyite socialist.
Unlike Obama, Trudeau, Macron and the rest
of the Zio Bush beast.
That's a recording of me doing Alex Jones.
Okay, so one America News.
Oann anchor Alison Steinberg did a globalist
rant about globalists tracking her through
her apartments.
I guess it's a nest thermostat with its energy
saving settings.
This is.
Yeah.
Let's just take a look at this.
And this is the level of delusion that now
is being that that we're now seeing it presented
in a serious manner.
Speaker 5: All right.
So I think it's pretty obvious we can all
agree the whole goal with these globalists
is to track us and trace us and monitor every
single thing that we do in our everyday lives.
In fact, this device that you're probably
watching me from, that you're holding in your
hand is doing just that right now.
And we know this.
This is not new news.
Okay.
However, I have just discovered another layer
of this.
That is what I believe, taking it a step too
far.
So I just moved into this new place, and this
next device came automatically installed.
Speaker 1: Oh.
Speaker 5: With the apartment.
It's the thermostat control, basically.
So it's really cold in here because there's
cement floors.
And I was constantly having to turn the heat
up.
Now, I realized it would get cold after I
turn the heat up.
Speaker 1: This is this is just the best.
I hope you guys see where this is going.
Speaker 5: On multiple occasions.
So I started thinking, why is this happening?
Now get this.
I'm going to show you the interface of this
and you're not going to believe it.
Okay.
So I'm having to turn it up again because
it went down to 70 and I wanted it at 73.
So it's having to heat up this.
Speaker 1: So my old place, when I when I
lived in Boston, my old place had this.
And when my tenants came in, the same thing
happened.
And they didn't ascribe it to the global,
as they described it, to the how the technology
works.
And I'll tell you how you fix this.
This this is the best.
Speaker 5: And because it keeps turning itself
back down.
And I was wondering, why is this happening?
Well, I decided to go to settings.
Mm hmm.
And then I found this HomeAway assist.
Then it says automatically use eco temperatures
when no one's home.
So that means this thing can track whether
or not I'm in my house.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, nest thermostats.
They have a proximity sensor.
So like when you walk by it.
It turns on so you don't have to press it.
Like if you want to just see what the temperature
is, you walk by and it senses you walk by
and it flips on and you go, Oh, it's 72.
So you don't have to click it or press it.
And it uses that to figure out whether you're
likely home or not.
Speaker 5: So this thing was turning itself
off when I wasn't home and then would automatically
start reheating when it since I was back inside.
Speaker 1: It must be the globalists.
Speaker 5: And if that's not creepy enough,
they also somehow now have my email address
because they keep harassing me and my inbox
to sign up for their stupid app so I can connect
to my phone.
Speaker 1: They're stupid.
Speaker 5: App.
It dropped even further.
This is absolute madness.
If you have a knife, turn off all these settings
because it's taking it way too far.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you can turn off all of these
settings.
I mean, listen.
At one point, I started to suspect that the
milk frother attachment on my espresso machine
had a camera in it and an RFID chip.
Because every time I made an espresso, I would
get an email offering me a coffee based vaccine.
It was crazy.
But then I realized, No, I'm wrong.
I'm an idiot.
Could she really believe this?
All of these thermostats have these functions.
The thermostats?
When I when I left my place in Boston and
tenants came in, I didn't use almost any of
these things because I had turned them off.
I like to control everything manually.
You know, I'm like, there's this type.
Some people are like, set it to automatic
and let's do it thing in the car with climate
control.
I don't want to control the fan speed and
I just go, I want 72 auto you figure out how
to get us to auto how to 72 at home.
I'm sort of more aware of like, okay, when
am I usually going to bed and I want it cool
or whatever.
So I turn all of this stuff, all this stuff
off.
I don't want the temperature changing when
I'm in and out.
I already am using more like eco friendly
temperatures during the day when I'm out at
work, you know, all these different things.
So when my tenants turned it on, they were
like, Hey, it's not doing anything.
And I said, Well, you've got to let it learn.
I never use that.
So you've got to let it learn your schedule.
And it's a smart thermostat.
You just turn it off.
There's no global ish global issue.
Yeah, it's just the way the technology's designed.
And I it's hard for me to know for sure whether
what you just saw is serious.
I just don't know.
It's very sick if it is, but maybe it's just
trolling.
That's Allison Steinberg from One America
News News Network.
You can just turn all that stuff off.
George Soros won't have any say.
Klaus Schwab.
Right.
Because remember, I know.
I know this is Allison Steinberg.
So she may be Jewish herself.
I've never met anyone named Steinberg who's
not Jewish, but globalist usually is talking
about rich Jewish men who want to control
everything, including the fan speed, apparently.
Now on your AC, very wild stuff.
And my question to you is simply, do you think
she's for real or do you think she's just
playing this up for
her audience?